welcome back here to good day
metro sheriff joe lombardo joining us
once again this morning for our morning
cup of joe segment sheriff good to see
you once again how you doing
hey john good to see you buddy all right
so may is a mental health awareness
month and you and i have talked before
about as there's
discussions of police reform trying to
get more help for
officers in the field to be able to
handle situations for folks who are
having episodes with their own mental
health so
what is metro doing to make sure
officers have that kind of crisis
training until there's some additional
resources moving forward
you know the way society has gone the
police are required to be experts in
just about everything homelessness
uh you know just about every social
issue as you can imagine and
and and we can't be an expert of that
that's the problem with it we have to
know a little bit about
everything and and but we do
provide that training that's necessary
to attempt to
de-escalate a situation when you
encounter individuals we provide that
40 hours of training in the academy
environment
and then every other year it's an eight
additional hours of training
associated with mental health a lot of
departments nationwide are seeing
officers quitting or retiring or leaving
the fours in seattle more than 200
officers left
in the past year in new york about 15
percent of the force left in 2020
what kind of attrition are you seeing at
metro
we are seeing an increase not similar to
other jurisdictions but we've seen a
slight increase
we have usually around 175 separations a
year here at metro
this last year we had an additional 60
so that's nothing to sneeze at or cough
at or just ignore
because that's a big number well sheriff
a very hard school year at ccsd other
schools in the valley wraps up here in
may
and this year once again we saw several
students that were awarded a scholarship
in the memory of
metro officers alan beckham igor saldo
let's talk about that fund we've covered
it here before you and i have talked
about it
how it helps students and again talk
about the officers that it's in
recognition of
yeah so that's a program uh that was a
brainchild of a local businessman
uh ron curry and partnership
in partnership with lvmpd police
foundation friends of metro
and his idea was to come forward because
there was there was
kids that were left fatherless as a
result of that event
and these kids were getting close to
attending college and you know there was
a fear that they would not be able to go
to college
in my understanding they've done well
over 350
000 in donations to kids
of metro police officers last october
sheriff metro launched
operation persistent pressure to try and
deal with some of the rising crime on
the las vegas strip
we're seeing tourism get back to normal
capacity limits are being lifted
do you anticipate another level of that
sort of enhanced enforcement or
increased
resources on the strip as we head into
the summer
i think it's important for us to provide
a safe environment down in the
in tourist corridor so we can have
repeat customers
i anticipate um we'll hopefully meet
that with success like we did
in the recent past sheriff lombardo
thank you very much for joining us this
morning once again and again if you at
home have a question for the sheriff we
will pose it to him
you can submit those questions on
eightnewsnow.com find out if it's
answered every wednesday